so one of my favorite qualities about
this movie and also any movie is when
it's so immersive that it makes you
wonder you know if I was in there would
I be able to hack it and survive so if
you guys were in the West in the 1850s
would you be able to make do and survive
and what do you think your job would
wind up being I think I could survive I
don't think other people be able to
survive my body odor that's my I think
that I would know I think I I'm actually
legally blind without my contact lenses
so know the answer to that question
would be known as true short sighted
thanks yeah i mean i probably have
spectacles the people be like ah he
likes a town yeah but might literally
they would be like like people would be
like that's the town yeah you'd be
making a spectacle of yourself a
spectacle between the four of you guys
in this cast who is the best chances of
surviving life this way who'd be the
best chance of well Joaquin's vegan so I
don't know if would you be able to
survive as a vegan in the American West
at that time absolutely hmm
absolutely yeah what it's a grass what
you think you're going is like the inn
and the saloon you'd be like yo I've
been taking special no grass a Western
to this Santa Monica there's no there's
potato there's a lot of potatoes during
that time we only ate what stick that
was a pre Cobb era no there was a lot
right there was a lot of dried meat
yeah jerky so people would sustain
themselves and so it meets can we get to
the answer so a lot of spiders so maybe
they have nutrients that I'm not aware
of he can do Pontius but who would
survive absolutely definitely not john c
reilly yeah absolutely
he would you would all assume that he'd
be the one that would and he would
definitely not be why don't you say that
cuz like dresses like someone who's a
cowboy yeah but his like comes from a
costume shop it's not like it's not you
know
yeah it's like its true like if you look
under the scarf that he wears it's like
Louis Vuitton you know it's like yeah
let's shoot yes states yeah you [ __ ]
those guys definitely taking it home we
would pull you would have done that oh
my did I go did he just swear this is
national this is Collider this is
national internet here I wanted to ask
about working with Jacques because I was
reading in the notes that he often
wanted to surprise you guys in the scene
so I was wondering is there any
particularly memorable curveball that he
threw you that maybe brought something
out that you didn't expect
Riz Ahmed yeah forget that costing I
agree wraps a little moment of of the
shoot and it was very excited you are
working with reason that again unveiled
my couture and shot that was great cut
off my head and I was there and I was
like he didn't watch night College no I
was like you didn't want to tell him
though that we had already done it cause
we really want to be in his films like
we love him so much
we didn't want him to know that yeah
halfway through the film we were like
yeah we've done a movie together
it's like had about the nothing good
defeated man pretty good he was like you
know no it can't be very good dad I
gotta have seen her - I was like you
know it's pretty good
did he ever end up watching it he's seen
the movie my god I mean I he's seen
about a hundred times what Michael Oh
sister be sisters brothers no no with
Nightcrawler he's watched that movie he
watched him he's watched it since Allah
yeah yeah he's a big fan of ours